hey youtubers is Charlie so the actor
that plays daredevil did this big
interview where he talks about Infinity
Ward daredevil season 3 defenders so I
tried to cut this down if you're new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get
everything I do Marvel and DC every week
but he talks about infinity war he talks
about filming defenders the action
scenes the comic book costumes is well
is a bunch of behind the scenes cool
Marvel stuff when he was originally
joining the show they had to do some
rights wrangling with Fox so I added a
little text as we go along just in case
you're not sure what he's talking about
when they get to those parts of the
interview but I'll recap that at the end
of this so there's some really cool
stuff in here so enjoy we have the
lovely Charlie Cox from Marvel's
daredevil Charlie hello hi just finished
the defenders the defenders yeah and
what I write anything you just finished
season 3 no no you know no I'd do that
later on the year that's like only go
back and do that you must be knackered I
did you know what I when we film
defenders we feel daredevil the first
two seasons of daredevil have destroyed
me yeah defenders are slightly different
because there's four of us
well the lot of the show we're not we're
not you know we can't all be together
all the time so there's a there's a lot
more effectively in its shooting
schedules a lot more time off great and
the way it worked out actually is it was
quite cool is that because my character
is the only one that has a mask they had
to when we did action sequences they
have to kind of make sure that they have
to make sure they get the other three
doing their bits right okay because they
can always use my son that'll if they
have your fight sequences are a might I
mean deadly very favorite over on and I
think a lot of it maybe because I just I
mean the story's great but the fight
sequences you do have a mass so your
stunt double you can get out mystery I
do I do do a lot I like because I love
that aspect of it and I really enjoy it
but but when when when dd-does do some
flying 720 flip kick whatever you call
it you you can pretty much because of
the speed in which is moving you can
pretty much film us straight on on my
double who's an amazing martial artist
and it and it cuts really nicely yeah if
if one of the other characters was to do
that it's still you'd still in those
moments better see probably so
right 100m Ryan I think one of the
reasons it works they actually goes work
well indeed is because of the and so how
long did it take to defend ISM I think
uh five months five in a bit that's not
a long talks only eight eight episodes
okay yeah so how long does it take the
desert understood twelve six months so
we had less time per episode it's quick
man whoa it'll work really quick so it's
quite we get I think we get four DD we
and Barry won again it's an action show
so yeah when you when you film a TV show
you know two three pages of dialogue it
takes a couple hours yeah but half a
page of action takes two days of course
yeah so till the excellent sequence
since you're doing if you're doing a
film it would take a couple of second
unit yeah I've heard of in you know a
month and months it probably yeah with
lots of rehearse I mean ideally turn up
and they're like right this is what
we're doing and then we have amazing son
team who've obviously they've been
working tirelessly for the for the
duration of the of the episode on it
yeah but no I thought we film DD we from
eight episodes on first unit and maybe
one or two days second unit Wow and do
you have so is it a bit we mean we've
got some questions but is it do you
bring in the daredevil stunt team the
Iron Fist something the Jessica Jones
and they just a whole new team for the
to defy they've got a whole new one and
and what your some double our study
doubles all remain the same right okay
that makes sense that was kind of father
that I see like so most because there
was any directors that you work with
yeah so it was I guess they it was the
Jews colony
yeah yes he was a kind of believe he was
kind of consultant on a whole thing and
he can he wrote one of the episodes I
don't know exactly which one which is
pretty cool um and but no we had think
so they did they've done now what for
series of thirteen episodes you know the
directors were essentially from what I
could work out the eighteen from those
four right there's four thirteen hour
slots they got the bed we got the best
ones the ones that yeah yeah great so
it's going to look amazing does it look
amazing I haven't seen anything I hope
so I I mean I when I when we're leaving
they they were
some of my bosses were saying s J
Clarkson who did the first two episodes
of Jessica Jones who actually did the
first episodes the defenders and they
were I was hearing very good things
about that so production in a Marvel
production of editing it but they've got
a Netflix of essentially say when they
want it it's not like you know regular
TV where they when you finish the last
episode they go right well it'll air in
four weeks or what yeah they just choose
a slot and stuff on it but like for me
like brick bringing the Punisher and
Anna lecture was just like a different
dimension for the first season yeah
like it just uh not Punishers got
sunshine I wasn't me and that sounds
great okay I mean he's just great a joke
I mean I do you really go through the
boxes me like he looks like one yeah
yeah no he definitely is yeah he's a
nice guy he's great yeah I mean look it
was I think that I was quite nervous
about season two because you know the
first season have been so grounded in
terms of the story we really didn't feel
like as hubiera show it felt like a
crime drama with this superhero kind of
element to it um because they knew they
were gearing towards the defenders and
because Danny Rand iron fist is one of
the defenders he and his world has to
operate in kind of mythological play
right you can't you can't ground that in
the same way that you can ground the
other show yeah so they knew that they
needed to start hinting towards that
mythological element and dv2 is a
perfect opportunity to do that because
the hand as a kind of ancient evil
organization yeah I'm gonna be cool do
exist within the daredevil comics so I
but I was personally I was like wow okay
so now we're we're asking and all the
authors you know the audience that we've
gained
- now suspend disbelief a little bit
further because we're going to involve
this committed mythological element
Karen page yeah Debra so then she had
this whole Punisher side thing which is
right and then um the other your best
mate
then he went else and yeah and I think
she even grounded it didn't it yeah I
think I mean I actually am seen hunting
but remember from what I remember in the
script yes yes that was very much that
was the hope it's hard man you know yeah
well you never know he's never no never
and I think for the most part you know
we you know people seem to really enjoy
that everyone's know if you're in
infinity there was a big it was a big
sum sum everyone got very excited
momentarily because I actually I don't
know the real story behind this but
everyone got very excited momentarily
because
townies Twitter feed released an image
that had all the names of the
superheroes on the Infinity Wars poster
yes yes on the affinity Wars poster and
and of course the the Netflix characters
were more honor yeah yeah so lot
suddenly there was a lot lot of people
took that to mean that we were going to
team up I have not received that phone
call okay
that's a Laurie because Marvel TV in
Marvel Studios is typically it's a
completely different it's not like TV
based in New York but then again I've
got Gregg Zaun on the in the Avengers
yeah you know why not and because a lot
of people ask me does do you think based
on that you know the kind of the tone
and the genre that DD that daredevil
show is it the Netflix show is in could
that coexist within them in a one of the
Avenger movies and I went back and had a
look at the comics to see how they
approached it and you know DD can't
compete with those guys not not really I
mean he's a street-level hero and he
doesn't have the superpowers in the same
way but his role within that his role as
a device in that in that in civil war is
really effective and he maintains his
kind of like his character and he you
know the panel's that he's in a slightly
they are slightly different that's you
know the comic element is just slightly
different there's less levity in those
moments yeah so I think it could have
worked but you know who knows maybe one
day sketchy so I'm very proud of ya you
know I've never been on social media
John Byrne's I was constantly getting
troubled I really not allowed so
shouldn't have done or blowback and I
was a bit depressed about that and this
audition came up for I just something
that I should do because there was no
woman daredevil didn't tell me that it
was Alex in something but eventually
I've got the job and I got to go and I
had to go and have a lunch with this
really wonderful man who's kind of who
resurrected daredevil the comic back in
the 80s and he's kind of one of the
great marble guys and he's a creative
influence on the show he's called Joe
Quesada I mean to have um I went to have
a lunch with him and he told me the
story which of course I'd know if I'd
have known during the process would have
changed it great Hill for me which was
that he essentially Fox made the movie
of daredevil bath years ago and they
owned the rights and so Marvel kind of
stud make that about there no they
didn't own it anymore and they weren't
gonna own it for many
years and then he had found out two
years prior that that Fox wanted some
more x-men stuff or something and they
were willing to trade and they're
willing to give back the rights to
daredevil and that was two years before
they even wrote the scripts you know he
said well my mate Ben Barnes is having a
lot of success having had a period of
time where he wasn't enjoying these
what's he doing because he played a kind
of a baddie in in West world and so now
he's on he's got this great character in
The Punisher show which I think he's
gonna know what I'm here that is gonna
be he's a really good actor look like a
lovely guy yeah the really dark in the
movies didn't he have to come in from
sort of a maybe but he's not if you
November and he's such a nice guy yeah
yeah and he's played lots of very nice
people ROM cogs so recapping the biggest
stuff he says that he's the only one
wearing a mask during defenders meaning
no Danny ran but maybe he'll get the
idea from watching daredevil do it here
because this looks an awful lot like
1940s Iron Fist he says that they're
getting ready to film daredevil season 3
a little bit later this year they're
filming Jessica Jones season 2 right now
he says he hasn't gotten any calls about
being an infinity war so that's just to
be determined not expecting TV
characters to crossover right now he
confirmed that all of the best people
from all the different Netflix shows
were pulled together to make defenders
so that just means the best of the best
writers people that make the action the
stunt team all the best stuff so if you
were worried about the stunt team from
Iron Fist or some other shows that you
weren't a big fan of doing this note do
not worry it's going to be amazing and
they've already confirmed the premiere
date is August 18th they've added a
teaser for that so I'll post a link to
that at the end of this but he also
talked about the Punisher TV show and
Ben Barnes they're supposed to premiere
that later this year too but there
hasn't been a confirmation for that yet
they're still finishing filming that
right now believe all your Marvel video
requests in the comments below but
what's going to happen next is I have a
cool Star Wars Darth Vader video that I
want to post celebrations happening next
week so I'll post an update about what's
going on with that so while you wait for
that to post you can click here for the
defenders teaser again and you can click
here for my new Rick and Morty thank you
so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you in the next video